bonsoir jean denis merci d'être avec
nous deux décennies de relations plus ou
moins tendues entre vladimir poutine et
les présidents américains successifs
mais là c'est le pompon si j'ose dire le
président américain qui prête le
président russe de tueurs ça fait un
petit peu de désordre quand même est-ce
que joe biden à a dépassé les limites
selon vous que cherchent-ils il est
clair que c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire ce n'est pas dans les usages
diplomatiques de qualifier le président
du gang puissance de 2 tu crois qu'au
pire moment de la guerre froide
ce genre de qualificatif n'a jamais été
n'a jamais été utilisée donc il est
manifeste que d'abord ça n'a pas été
utilisé au hasard ça illustre la
dégradation des relations entre les
états unis démocrates et la russie
actuelle et en fait on voit bien que
prolonge un petit peu l'état d'esprit
que byden en tant que vice-président de
d'obama avait à l'époque et donc on voit
que la politique démocrate vis-à-vis de
la russie sera très dur en plus ça
manifestent une certaine
comment dirais-je on passe un peu la
russie par profits et pertes dans le jeu
triangulaire avec que pékin puisque
visiblement si on veut essayer de faire
en sorte que la russie ne soit pas trop
proche de pékin dans ce jeu triangulaire
on devrait plutôt essayer de l'aménager
ce n'est pas le cas je crois que la
russie dans le la rivalité pékin et
washington est passée un peu par profits
et pertes
d'ailleurs joe biden un qui dit
clairement a dit mirko think il en
paiera le prix
pourquoi ce discours aussi dur que
justement avec la russie et est plus
tendre avec peut-être des pays
ma foi peut-être moins fréquentables
aussi alors je crois d'abord qu'il ya un
côté psychologique important cette
histoire d'interférence dans les
élections américaines a des conséquences
psychologiques beaucoup plus grave qu'on
imagine peut-être en dehors des états
unis
la démocratie américaine est considérée
comme iconique si je puis dire par ses
citoyens et donc le fait qu'on accuse la
russie d'avoir d'être intervenu dans le
processus électoral a du poids est un
élément qui n'est pas à négliger dans le
dans la proche enfin dans les propos
tenus par ben hayden la deuxième chose
aussi c'est que le bail den depuis qu'il
est arrivé au pouvoir se présente un peu
comme le chef du camp démocrate
elle veut créer une espèce de solidarité
fondée sur la promotion de la démocratie
les droits de l'homme les américains se
valent à nouveau un peu le gendarme ce
genre de choses pour créer un camp
démocratique et évidemment les propos
tenus contre le président russe
s'inscrivent dans cette dans cette
logique du jeu alors donné le camp
démocratique justement alors l'allemagne
semble vouloir faire partie de ce qu'on
va faire voilà ce n'est pas une surprise
mais l'allemagne a clairement pris est
parti aujourd'hui pour washington
soutient joe biden dans ses propos la
france va suivre selon vous sa série ne
peux pas vous le dire
en général ce genre de propos n'est pas
conforme à usage diplomatique est en
général rend la france essaye de de
respecter ces usages alors en tout cas
le chef de la diplomatie anthony blinken
américain en a profité pour appeler
toutes les entités impliquées dans le
projet controversé du gazoduc nord
stream ii entre la russie et l'allemagne
à se désengager
diatement sous peine de sanctions des
etats-unis a pas une forme d'ingérence
caractérisée dans le fait justement
d'appeler ces pays à se désengager sous
peine de sanctions mais je crois que
l'extra territorialité de droit
américain et brandi depuis déjà 20
depuis le temps d'obama en fait et quand
on entre dans un système de sanctions
vis-à-vis de la russie en vente dans un
système aussi où le gouvernement des
états unis le ministère des finances et
des affaires étrangères juge si le
respect ou le non respect des sanctions
par d'autres entreprises d'autres pays
et préjudiciable aux intérêts
concurrentiel delà de la rue de l'est
des états unis et donc
l'extraterritorialité du système des
sanctions est une donnée est acquise
pour les états unis qui s'en servent
comme il le souhaite alors à cette
escalade verbale entre les deux
présidents s'ajoute la question de la
crimée à sept ans après le g7 ne
reconnaîtra pas les tentatives de la
russie visant à légitimer l'occupation
de la crim r je cite les propos du g7
donc sept ans après le dossier n'est
souvent pas tôt bien je crois que au
contraire il et il revient à la surface
et ça n'est probablement pas un hasard
je vous rappelle que dans les accords de
minsk qui avait été signé en tout cas
pas trop mais aussi nié par la france
l'allemagne les états unis le pardon au
contraire la russie et l'ukraine
il n'est pas fait mention de la crimée
donc ce approuvé l'annexion d'activer
par la russie les pays européens jusque
là considéré que l' affaire ne devait
pas être mise sur le sur la table si on
voulait régler les points les plus durs
le fait que la lacune mais reviennent à
la surface et manifestement le signe
d'un durcissement de la situation
internationale
la crimée
le crès namur remis laquelle l'akp est
mis sur la table et les etats unis l'ont
remise aussi donc c'est un c'est un
signe qui ne trompe pas de l'aggravation
de la situation la commune de ternat
vers celle qui parle toujours de
l'annexion illégale il ya pourtant eu un
référendum ça n'a aucune valeur aux yeux
de ces pays et quel que soit j'allais
dire le les fondements historiques ou
les justifications stratégique et le
voeu des populations en termes de droit
international stricto sensu il s'agit
d'une d'une annexion mais évidemment par
la suite il pourrait y avoir un
référendum reconnu par la communauté
internationale qui prendra en compte le
voeu manifeste de la majorité de la
population qu même d'être rattachée à la
russie merci beaucoup jean denis gasquet
directeur de recherche à l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques d'avoir été avec nous